is there uh a dream guest or
mother-daughter duo that you would love
to have
on the podcast that's a good question
what about
courtney and chris would you want them
on the show have you talked to them
about this
um i would totally love to have them on
the show i think it would be hilarious
i love courtney and chris so much so i'm
sure it'd be really interesting to kind
of compare like their relationship to
ours and
see things but who knows in the future
what that holds
well speaking of the kardashians if they
could appear on your podcast is there a
chance
that you will appear on keeping up with
the kardashians
i don't know who knows what the future
holds i'm kind of just living life
day by day and going through everything
with a
happy heart and um humble mindset so
it's been all really exciting
a lot of stuff keeps uh continuing to be
presented to me which is super fun
and i think there's just plenty of
opportunities and exciting things coming
up
so you wouldn't say no if they were like
could we roll the cameras
um i feel like i'm really not a person
to say no to anything at any time ever
yeah i think we talked about that we
actually did talk about that on the
podcast
i can never say no to anybody you know
let alone
something i actually am interested in
doing but in general we've talked about
that on the podcast that i am for sure
a yes woman because i say yes to
everything even whenever i don't want to
in navigating fame i mean has courtney
have kim have any of those
karjenners given you any advice on
navigating
fame just because you've been spending
so much time with them i feel like i get
the same kind of advice from everyone
that i meet that's in this
entertainment industry or in this world
and it's kind of just you know
never let it get to the point where
you're just not enjoying it and try to
really take in every moment that you
have presented to you and take it like
it's your last one and just make it the
best and i feel like that's
like i said that's what everyone's told
me that's been in this industry and
world for so
long and i've kind of just relayed that
to my family and been like you know
who knows how long any of this will ever
last and like life is so short so why
not just really take advantage of
everything and
um do everything that makes you happy
now while you can what about
for mom how has it been to watch her
career and her star sort of grow so big
over the past few months
it's been really crazy and amazing and
i just i'm so proud of her really oh
that's so sweet
addison you posted i think you're part
of kim kardashian skim's one year
anniversary campaign
yeah i am which has been incredible and
super exciting and
um when i got presented the opportunity
i was so grateful
and so blessed and it's kind of
something that was different than i
normally would do
um and a little bit like out of my
comfort zone for
you know where i am but it was so
exciting and so fun and
um definitely an opportunity i'm glad i
didn't miss how did that
opportunity come your way i mean does
chris reach out does kim reach out
i mean it was kind of just through
conversation and it got started and then
um it led up to the shoot and then the
billboard in soho which is
insane for me to even think about i feel
like i don't even grasp
like the actual like value
yeah the entire thing is just so crazy
to me because it's like it happens so
fast that i'm like
i like don't have a really like a minute
to process everything at once so like
when i do it like all hits me at once
and i'm like what's going on here like
what is my life
a lot of people have judged your
relationship with courtney just because
of the age gap
what do you have to say to those people
um i think that
at the end of the day i think
friendships are
kind of just i mean what you make them
and what you have like the time you
spend with them the things you
enjoy doing and if you have things in
common um it kind of just makes sense
and i don't think that's anything
to really judge people on i feel like
friendships can range from any age and
i feel like everyone can relate to
people in different ways and courtney
and i just happen to
have a great friendship which is really
fun and she's been a great
person to have in my life and she she
said in my youtube video that
i had great energy that she liked to be
around but i think she has great energy
as well and she has
so much experience in her life that um i
can really just look at and
um kind of learn from yeah sherry have
you met them yet have you met courtney
yes i have met courtney i think we love
most too is like my mom always used to
be very like
organic and like all like the essential
oils and like just stuff like that and
courtney loves that stuff too because
i like love her pooch um website and
like all of her recipes and i'm like
all right let's learn how to cook this
because when i eat it at courtney's it's
really good
i love that too and i've been making
smoothies
that she taught me from courtney so yeah